I'm a data charmer at go data driven
don't ask me what that actually means
um and I want to talk to you about
protocols and why you actually need them
or in fact mostly what are protocols now
in order to fully appreciate the
usefulness of protocols to see why you
actually need them I think it's useful
to go all the way from well what is
dynamic versus static typing type hints
then ABCs and finally protocols so if
you're familiar with one or more of the
first Concepts bear with me all the way
in the end I'll talk about protocols
so
um let's first talk about typing in
Python so python is a dynamically typed
language you might know that
so what does that mean so let's have a
look at what dynamic typing versus
static typing is so here on the left
side
you see some python code so a function
my function and this takes three
arguments a b and c and then it when you
call it it returns some kind of so it
does an operation on those arguments and
then Returns the results
um and so the return type of dysfunction
it depends on the arguments that you put
in so if you put in five three and two
you'll get an integer as output
on the other hand if you put in 5.1 3
and 2 you'll get a floating Point number
these types they are checked at runtime
and as you can see type decorations are
not required I mean I haven't defined
any types in the in the definition of
the function and well the only way we
can or the only way I have played around
with the types is by just the values of
the arguments I put in there
on the other hand so on the right you'll
see an example of a statically typed
language so in this case we have to
specify the return type of the function
in this case it's an integer and then
the function name with three arguments
again a b and c and those three
arguments are all integers
um it explicitly says that so now when
you in such a language when you try to
call this function with three integers
you'll get an integer back and when you
do this with a float as one of the
arguments you'll get an error
and these types are not checked at
runtime typically but they are checked
at compile time
this does mean that type declarations
are required as you can see both the
return types as well as the argument
types are specifically
um so are specified there they're right
right in the code
so there are pros and cons of both kinds
of languages with Dynamic typing you
don't have to really worry so much I
mean as long as the arguments that you
put in there work with the operations
that you do in the function everything's
fine but if something's not fine you
might only find out at runtime maybe
after quite a while of running or maybe
on a machine of someone else who uses
your code and that's not so nice while
with static typing
you well you have to specify all those
types explicitly but the types are
checked at compile time which is nice
um of course there so there's another uh
um category of languages in here untyped
programming languages those are
something completely else let's not talk
about them entirely
um so yeah so like I said
um python is a dynamically typed
language
um Dynamic typing we also call that duct
typing
um because if something works like a
duck and it quacks like a duck then we
just assume it is a duck
um so in other words if some object that
you put into a function has the required
functionality then we should just accept
it why wouldn't we right
so let's have an example here so suppose
that we have a class duck and a duck can
walk and Quack obviously right so we can
make an instance of a duck and then we
can make the duck walk and Quack
that's awesome
now if we make a glass donkey and a
donkey can certainly walk but the donkey
cannot quack at least I haven't heard a
donkey quack
then we can make another duck of type
donkey and we can try to make this dark
walk and Quack but when we try to do so
at runtime we'll get an attribute error
saying that the donkey object doesn't
have an attribute that's named quack
um what
of course it's easy to see what what
goes on here
but in a more complicated complex
complex
program you might find out uh really
late so that is not tonight is it only
this error so this is only really
checked at runtime
um
so now if instead of a donkey we have
some kind of imposter duck which isn't
really a duck but well it can work and
it can sort of try to crack not quite
quacking then of course it's fine to
just make a dark hoof type imposter duck
and make it work and make it work Quack
The Imposter duck behaves like a real
duck so well we should just accept it as
being a duck right I really like that
about python you don't really have to
worry about what the type is of
something that you put in as an argument
you just make sure that it has the
functionality or it behaves like the
object that you would expect it to do
so then as a wrap up of this first part
um
python is a dynamically typed language
which well and I like that you don't
have to you don't really have to specify
any type declarations that's nice
because you can just quickly code
something together gives you lots of
flexibility you can create an imposter
duct that behaves like a duck that
actually isn't a duck
um but as a downside you don't have any
type checking except at runtime and
sometimes runtime is just too late
so in order to fix that last downside we
have typings
um also called optional static typing
and it was introduced in Python 3.5
and usually that goes together with my
pi and my pie is the well the optional
static type checker for Python and so
according to their description they aim
to combine the benefits of dynamic or
duct typing and static typing
um you might know python you might know
my time sorry you might also not buy
them at least I hope
um
so suppose
for an example of how to use type hints
um suppose that we have a class duck and
this duck can eat bread and it can swim
now then we can have a function called
feed the duck it takes a duck as
argument and here after the argument
name I've specified a type hint namely
that I expect this duck to be of type
duck
and then I can have this duck eat bread
um well that should work because the
doctor has a method that is called eat
bread
now when we instantiate adoc then we can
just wait we can call this function we
can use it on the duck and the duck is
fed red oh that's cool
um
now then if we have a monkey a monkey
can eat bananas and climb the tree if we
can then try to feed a duck feed the
duck use this feed the duck function on
the monkey
um we'll get in an attribute error
saying that the monkey object doesn't
have any attribute called eat bread well
that's correct but that's at runtime but
if we would use my bike beforehand
before runtime it would already tell you
that this argument one will feed the
duck so the only argument is actually of
type monkey and it you it would expect
it to be a duck
so here my bike can really help you spot
any issues with your code before runtime
so that's cool
now for a much more generic function
um
let's
um so again we have this this glass duck
and the duck can eat bread and now we
have a much more generic function that
can feed bread to any animal and in this
case we specify this is that this animal
must be of type duck
um
that's cool but now suppose that there's
yet another animal maybe a pig
and a pig can also eat bread
then we would should we well we really
have to adapt the type end of the feed
bread function to also accept a big
because otherwise my Bible one warn us
that a big is not a duck which is true
so now here I've adapted the
um the type hint for the animal argument
to be of Union a union of a duck and a
pig basically saying we either accept
ducks or pigs
um
now this is all fine this is perfect but
now suppose that this code is in some
package that I download from bye bye
it's called Animals
and
um here is a class mace mace is my baby
boy and he really likes to eat bread he
can also drink milk
um his two favorite activities
now if I instantiate a an instance of
Mace
and then try to feed bread to maize
um at runtime that would work fine
because maze has a e-bred method
but
my Bible warn us that this argument one
of feed bread has an incompatible type
mace while expected a union of a duck or
a pig
so while the function would work on this
class maze
um
you cannot have my pie sort of accept
this as long as you are unless you can
adapt the type hint of this function
yourself
if you can't if the function is in
someone else's code then you cannot add
any other class to this Union in the
typing so you're basically stuck of
course you can have my by ignore this
issue if you really know for sure that
is fine
um but well it's not so beautiful
so as a wrap up for typins
um
type declarations they're optional
that's really nice so you don't have to
but you can and when you do you get
optional static type checking so before
runtime you get a warning when something
is wrong
but you cannot adapt type hints of
imported code so if you make something
that's compatible well you can't tell
the other library that you made
something that is compatible with them
so that's not so nice
okay let's move on
ABC's abstract-based classes
so what are they
um here's an example so ABCs are our
base classes so classes that you can
inherit from but they cannot be
instantiated so typically they're used
to define the interface of what
subclasses should look like
and so here I have an a base class
called Animal
which has an abstract method so not not
implemented method called walk now
forgive me for assuming that all animals
can walk all animals that we'll use in
this presentation can surely walk
now we cannot instantiate an animal
because well an animal is a base class
is abstract we cannot use it so if we
try to instantiate an animal we'll get
at runtime we'll get a type error saying
that we cannot do that
what we can do though is we can define a
class duck that inherits from animal and
that can work and now we can instantiate
the duck and this duck is then an
instance of animal
one okay so that's cool
so how is this useful
now suppose that we
[Music]
um
want to go back to the previous example
with bread eating then we can make a
base class that called that's called eat
eat bread
that defines that all supplies should
have a method that is called eat bread
and then we can Define duck and pig both
to be to inherit from this eats bread
Base Class
and now in the feed bread function all
we need to do is specify that this
animal should be of type eat bread and
an animal then we know that animal can
eat bread
so now if I were to import this code
from some package I found somewhere and
use it with my baby boy I would Define
his class to be mace that inherits from
each bread
and then I can Define how he can eat
bread and drink milk and I can well I
can use an instance of maize with this
function that works fine
typically though those base classes are
not so easily exposed in packages that I
tend to use so then instead of having to
import or being able to import feed
bread and eat bread from animals you'd
have to find this eat spread base class
somewhere deep inside the Library
somewhere like from animals.base dot
eats import each spread
um but still this works fine
alternatively if you don't really want
to inherit from The Base Class you can
explicitly register
your class as being a subclass of a an
abstract-based class
so that's what I do here so I Define the
class mace which doesn't inherit from
each spread but then I register mace as
well a subclass of eat spread so in this
case Maize still is so an instance of
may still is an instance of each bread
although it didn't inherit any
functionality that I may have defined in
each spread in this case of course I
didn't Define any functionality in the
eat spread Base Class I only defined
that well an abstract method without any
implementation so
in this case it's
exactly the same as the previous example
but in some cases you might want to
register a subplus without inheriting
any functionality that has been
defined already
um so this this all works fine right
this is pretty beautiful
um but sometimes
um
you might still run into issues so
suppose that there is this package
animals that defines the Base Class
animal and a dog that can walk and a
function that can walk an animal
um and then there's yet another package
that's called Lamas that defines the
llama and the Llama can also walk right
llamas can walk
now if in our code we import this walk
animal function from the animals package
and then the Llama object from the
llamas package
then sure at runtime we can walk the
Llama that's all right but might buy
will complain that llama is actually not
ASAP class of an animal which is true
because well they're from different
packages so why would it be
of course what you could do is fix that
by registering llama to be a subclass of
animal
but
this is feels kind of fishy to me
because you're really
changing the internals of packages
you're using you're using right
um
it works it's not super nice
so wrap up for so far abstract based
classes they give a lot more structure
to your types that's nice Thai pins in
this way won't need updates for new
subclasses so you can add as many
animals of you if you as you want but
you'll never have to update all those
type hints that say animal it's
automatically included
um
but you may still in some cases have
difficulties combining classes from
multiple libraries won't happen too
often and you might be able to be okay
with that but I don't think it's so nice
and those virtual subclasses so there's
subclasses that don't inherit that you
can explicitly register register
um well that's also nice but you still
need to explicitly register them which I
also don't like so much
so now we'll come finally to protocols
also called structural subtyping or
static duct typing and those were
introduced in Python 3.8
and protocols make everything that we've
encountered so so far much and much more
beautiful
so let's have a look how
so a protocol is a special case of
abstract Base Class
and here I Define a glass eat spread
that is a protocol
that defines so this function this or
sorry this method eats bread without any
implementation and then I Define a
function feed bread that takes any
animal as argument and the animal should
be of type each each spread so that the
function can make the animal eat bread
now if we define a class so when we
define a class called duck that has a
method that is eat bread it's called eat
bread then this is automatically and
implicitly considered to be a subtype of
each spread
but only when typing
so this protocol automatically
um so this this class duct is
automatically a subtype of the protocol
that defines
um what um
what these classes that adhere to this
protocol should look like and as duck
implements all the attributes and
methods that this protocol defines in
this case it's just one it is
automatically a of type beat spread
until now if we call feed bread on the
duck that's okay both at runtime as well
as when type check
now if I were to import that function
from a package of feed from animals
import feed bread and then again define
a class mace then mace is also
implicitly a subtype of each spread
because it implements it implements a
method that's called e-brid and again I
can call this function feed bread on
Maze and that works so fine without
having to do anything at all all I need
to do is make sure that the required
functionality is there so it hasn't the
class mace has a method that's called
ebred that's all I need to do and then
everything works fine
that's pretty nice isn't it
so actually before this there were
already some kind of protocols that
um so before python 3.8
there were some protocols that we were
used to
um like knowing and playing around with
so if you've already used some type
hints with for example an iterable of a
certain type or an iterator of a certain
type or a sized
um
then well in effect what happened was
just checking that
the object whatever it was in the case
of iterable it should have had the
dender iter method for an iterator this
were the dunder next and thunder either
methods for the size is the thunder Len
so now since python 3.8 these are actual
protocols but before those before that
time
um those were sort of
not really protocols but behaved at
least like those
um
so now Protocols are mainly
were mainly designed to be used when
type checking so for my buy so before
you ever run your code make sure that
all those typings
that you use the functions according to
the type pins
but you can actually use them at runtime
on the other hand so if you just do that
like this so we have this protocol
that's called eat bread and it defines
that all
whole classes that are each spread
should have the method eat bread and we
create the duck that can eat bread
then a duck is not an instance of each
spread it is only at when type checking
but if you really wanted to you can make
this happen by using this runtime
checkable decorator
if you add this to your protocol
then suddenly any object that
adheres to the protocol
becomes an instance of that protocol at
runtime
um note that this knot isn't completely
safe
because at runtime this only checks the
existence of the protocol numbers the
protocol members sorry and their names
and it doesn't check the signatures so
if you implement
a a method that is called eat bread that
actually takes arguments and it would
still be an instance of each bread while
while type checking that wouldn't be the
case so it's not completely
but still you can do something with this
without ever having to explicitly
specify that duck is a off-type eat
bread this just magically makes it work
so wrapping up
um protocols as I said I think this
makes all of what we've seen so much
more beautiful because there's no need
to inherit or register anything there
are no more difficulties combining
libraries because well it just
implicitly makes it work as long as the
right methods are defined
um if you want to use this at runtime
make sure to decorate your protocol with
the runtime checkable decorator and
beware that it's not completely safe
although in practice you'll probably be
fine
and so this protocols gives us the best
of both worlds static type checking
whenever you want it and dynamic type
dynamically typed language like python
but also static checking of dynamic
types with protocols
so that brings me to the end I hope I've
convinced you that you do need protocols
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
anyone have any questions
all right you want to come up to the my
career
so a question what pitfalls do you see
of using prototype because string a lot
of magic in the background yeah
I I don't really think
um that there's a lot of magic in the
background
um it
[Music]
um
so type checking in Python is just about
comparing signatures right and in the
case of protocols you just compare also
well the existence of members and
attributes of a class and you you can
just simply Define what any object that
you expect should look like instead of
being explicitly like that object
now like I said when using this at
runtime maybe you should be a little bit
careful
but
so for type checking I don't really see
any pitfalls
yeah the thanks for the talk by the way
the runtime checking this is also
go to the Super command I mean it's a
sort of implicit subtype but the it
won't be findable via super right it
doesn't go to the init of the protocol
class uh no I don't I assume not I I to
be honest I haven't worked with that uh
I see people saying that but
um as you don't Define any functionality
in a protocol just the existence of
attributes and methods there shouldn't
be any
functionality inside the initializer of
the protocol anyway yeah it should and
the protocol itself is that an abstract
thing or can you actually
work with that direct so the protocol
exists at runtime but as it hasn't so
there's no implementation of any of the
methods or attributes it wouldn't be
very useful except for maybe if you want
um but doesn't throw this error like ABC
class it's like
um I've never tried to instantiate a
product yeah
well thanks for the answer
more in-person question if anyone has a
other one
foreign
is something a protocol if it has a
property but the property returns a
attributor or not implemented error oh
wow now we're really getting into the
nitty-gritty details
um I don't know
um I would hope so but I don't know
thank you
did we have any remote questions
okay
all right
um if that's it then please let's con
say thanks to our guest and thank you
[Music]
[Applause]